Another way to visualize and evaluate
the accuracy of a regression algorithm
is to look at the relationship
between predicted and
actual values of our
dependant variable Y.
Here's what I mean, query our model,
the one that we trained on training
data with Xtest, our testing data set.
The output of that query is a new
vector of Y values, Ypredict.
So based on this Xtest data our
model predicts this Ypredict data.
We can now compare what we know
to be the correct, or true,
data and
Ytest with what our prediction was.
So this pair would appear
somewhere on this chart, say here.
So its a value along the horizontal
access here is what the prediction was
and along the vertical axis
was what the ground truth is.
So we can plot these pairs
all the way through our data.
Now, if this scatterplot is arranged
in approximately a nice line like this,
that means we've got a pretty
good prediction algorithm.
On the other hand,
if they're not aligned so well and
they look sort of like a shotgun blast,
our learner is not so good.
We can measure this
property quantitatively
using something called correlation.
You can use the num pi function corrcoef
to measure the correlation
between Ytest and Ypredict.
You'll get an answer
somewhere between -1 and +1.
Where +1 means they're
strongly correlated,
-1 means they're inversely correlated,
and
0 means there's essentially no
correlation at all between them.
One thing to point out here is
that correlation isn't the slope
of this line.
Lots of people think that's what it is.
Correlation has to do with how well
aligned the points are with the line
that we fit.
So if it's a nice oval that
fits close to that line,
we usually have a high correlation.
If it's a big round thing
we've got poor correlation.